يشغل قطاع غزه المنطقه الجنوبيه من السهل
الساحلي الفلسطيني على البحر المتوسط على
شكل شريط ضيق شمال شرقي شبه جزيره سيناء
يمتد القطاع على مساحه 360 كيلو مترا
مربعا بطول ثلاثه واربعين كيلو مترا اما
عرضه فيتراوح بين خمسه كيلومترات و15 كيلو
مترا ويقتله حوالي مليونين
و254 الف نسمه في يونيو حزيران من عام
2007 اعلنت اسرائيل غزه كيانا معاديا وفي
اكتوبر تشرين الاول من العام نفسه فرضت
عليه حصارا شاملا بعد سيطره حركه حماس
عليه يرتبط قطاع غزه بثلاثه معابر اثنان
تسيطر عليهما اسرائيل وهما معبر كارما ابو
سالم التجاري جنوبي القطاع ومعبر بيت
حانون شمالي القطاع والثالث هو مع مع مصر
ورغم ان البحر المتوسطه هو المتنفس الوحيد
لغزه فان اسرائيل هي التي تتحكم في مساحه
الصيد المخصصه للقطاع والتي تتراوح بين
سته اميال بحريه الى 15 ميلا ومنذ بدء
الحصار دخل قطاع غزه في ست حروب مع
اسرائيل خلال 15 عاما بدات عام 2008
بمعركه الفرقان وصولا الى عام 2022
بمعركه وحده الساحات
[موسيقى]